[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story live from the
headquarters of ramsey solutions
broadcasting from the dollar car rental
studio
this is the dave ramsey show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life your work and your money
i'm john deloney host of the dr john
deloney show and part of the ramsey
network i'm here with my good friend and
colleague
host of the world famous ken coleman
show the one and only mr ken coleman how
are you doing good man
you actually have to turn your mic on
you actually have to hit that on button
folks a little behind the scenes
there's a square right here and it says
on and when you press it
the mic works so there you go but i'm
doing well friend it's always
good to be with you we had a blast
together
not too long ago oh you were looking at
that funny video i was yeah it looks
good
we like to share videos together we all
sit in the same room and uh dude we had
a blast last time talking
we talked money we took money calls we
also took calls about
your side of the things relationships
tell them what you do tell them what i
do and what we're going to take today
so dave likes to remind people that for
for
25 30 years he's talked to people about
getting out of debt
about their money and that money is a
symptom
usually of bigger challenges in folks
life the way you handle money is often
how you handle
other crisis in your life and so i do
mental health i've got a history of
working in crisis response
working with relationships helping
people make the next right decision when
things feel like it's all piling in on
top of them yeah
and you do it well well i appreciate
that and one of the big crossovers that
you and i have
yeah is people look in the mirror they
don't like themselves they struggle in
their relationships they struggle with
their money
and that carries over into the place
where they spend most of their time
every day which is
work that's right and you know the world
view that most people have of work
john is that i work to live
in other words i work to get a paycheck
so that i can take care of my basics we
talk about the four walls of ramsey and
then if we got a little left over some
memories some vacations
maybe some toys and the problem with
that world view of work is that
work just becomes this utilitarian
function that i just say
well if if this is what i do i work to
live
and then i start to think that my life
is worth my salary
and if i don't have as many toys or i
don't have as big a house
or you know it puts the wrong emphasis
on work
right if work is just about money or
value money being monetary value you and
i talk about this that's exactly right
well the ramsey solutions world view of
work is that we
live to work now some people are going
what
no no no it's not workaholic it's not
putting all my value in work it's not
that i live and i don't i don't value my
family i don't value relationships
it's just all about the climb and i just
live to work well no no no
it's that let's take the word work and
let's switch it out for a second and
call it
contribute i live to contribute i
was created to contribute
now it's different right now we find
purpose in our work
so where does this come from you don't
have to train a kid john you and i both
have kids you don't have to train a kid
to say no
you don't have to train a kid how to
steal a toy from their friend
there's just certain things that we as
humans come into this world hardwired to
do nobody tells us how to do it
one of the things that we do as humans
we all lay awake at some point in our
life and we go why am i here yeah you
and i agree on this
we i think purpose in your life is
achieved in two major areas
relationships that's where you
specialize
i was created to play a role in my
relationships
for me husband father
brother community member son teammate
right
community member in in williamson county
whatever
and then the other side is work purpose
in our work
so when i say that we are created to
contribute that we
were created to work it's that our
purpose in our work
is about blessing others or
contributing to others so i was created
to fill a unique role because i was
given talent things i do well
i was given passion which means i love
to do certain things you'd have to teach
me that i just figured it out one day oh
i love doing this
hate doing this and then we all long to
create results that matter to us for
some of you are listening today or
watching
you want to help single moms i took a
call today on the ken coleman show lady
wants to
leave a successful career in accounting
to work
for a non-profit to stop sex trafficking
there's a deep why there yep there's a
result
that she's looking to put out there and
so that's the beauty of it so
that's the that's the answer is to
figure out wait a second what was i
created to do
and there's multiple answers multiple
jobs multiple career paths multiple
dream jobs if you want to say that
but that's where we all are united
through politics
geography all out the window what unites
us all at least one thing
so we all want to make a difference in
the world and so i
so there you go my default setting ken
is to
look at i want to be a doctor i want to
help i want to help
stop you know sex trafficking i want to
fill in the blank
i was going through the attic putting
some christmas stuff away
and i had that moment that we've all had
where you look up and you go oh my gosh
is that a leak
and then i got a flashlight and looked
closer and closer and sure enough
i got this metal roof that you know the
leaks coming through or all the
the little grommets have have ground
away call the roofer out
he walks through it with me ken that guy
was alive
yeah he was his whole thing was i'm
gonna help
he said i do roofs in williamson county
which if you don't know is where
big fancy houses are right and i'm even
out way out in the country
right where the houses aren't so big and
so fancy listen
he took it upon himself to say hey
there's people out there helping other
people get well
we got doctors out here we've got
musicians out here we've got business
owners out here
i'm going to make sure their house stays
whole their families stay
warm i'm going to make sure they have a
roof on their house and he felt it man
he feels alive
let me tell you why this is so great
we'll break it down talent passion
mission right
here's with that guy he's really
talented at fixing stuff
yeah fixing things there are some people
like you who are talented at fixing
people
uh or walking with people right yeah
yeah
this guy likes working with his hands
he's good at working with his hands he's
good at fixing stuff he loves solving
problems that's passion
what kind of problems do you want to
solve thing problems but in solving
thing problems fixing a hole in the roof
you i mean he was the most popular
person in your house
not you right your wife loved him more
in that moment
she said you why he was really good
looking but also
he can actually solve our problems he
solved a massive stress
problem for the deloney family and so
guys that are working on hvac systems
plumbing problems at three in the
morning your work matters as much
as the brain surgeon but he could walk
around this community
because his head held low good because
we all as a roofer right that's all i do
and he's tapped into something bigger
yeah he's playing a larger role he's a
he's a
he's a cornerstone of our community
because he sees himself that way so
here's the deal that's where john and i
we're on the same page so we can take
your money questions we can take your
relationship questions you know you got
your your house blowing up you're having
ugly political conversations uh
you got a boss who is just an absolute
nightmare
bully oh we love those because we take
them on from a different way
and so we're going to take your work
questions if you want to learn how to
get promoted ken
i want to know how to present better in
the office in my next meeting my next
presentation
uh i i need help with this problem hey
ken
you helped me the other day president
better when you looked at the way i was
dressed and you said
come on man it is true we may discuss
that i did have to help him
it was uh it was hard but he got it it
was all in good fun
you just can't wear those shoes and be a
doctor that was what it boiled down to
there's a little teeth evidently we're
not pinch rolling our pants anymore
america
hey we're going to that one this is the
dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters
with easy online ordering free shipping
and a guaranteed perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
so
welcome back to the dave ramsey show i'm
john dalone with my good friend ken
coleman
we are taking your calls on your life
your work
your purpose your relationships and
we'll even take a few money calls
and our advice will be worth the price
you pay for it
let's go to esteban in orlando florida
esteban how are we doing
we're doing amazing guys how are y'all
doing very very good
how can we help man um well first of all
i'd like to thank y'all for
the work that you guys do god bless all
the ramsey personalities uh you guys
have been a great impact in my life um
uh so my question is the following i'm
currently in baby step two
i am basically two thousand two hundred
and sixty dollars away
from jumping into baby set three hey hey
boy
way to go man that's awesome yeah
appreciate it um
i spoke to ken over a year ago i work in
the
service industry right now um however
i've always wanted to do digital
illustrations
last year i landed a contract with a
person
in another state i thought i began
what is it advertising myself and i've
gotten side jobs by commissions
now uh because the entry wasn't
consistent
i did uh follow uh ken coleman's
advice for you know for setting up an
interview and landing a job
and i'm currently heading on to i'm
heading to one today
oh yeah nowhere it's nowhere near my
sweet spot
um so my question is the following okay
should i
take the job if it's ever you know
offered to me um
or should i continue my side job and the
reason why i'm asking that is because
given my
uh the fact that i have a full time and
this will be my second uh
job it wouldn't leave space
for doing any more illustrations and
you're current
and you're currently making some money
here and there
contract uh work for digital
illustrations is that correct
yes sir no i would not take this second
job you've already got a full-time job
and you're
2 200 uh away from
being debt-free then you begin to work
on baby step 3 and that's at that 3-6
months
i wouldn't take it if you're getting
you're still getting jobs doing digital
illustration because that is bringing
some extra money that's going to help
with the whole
uh baby step plan uh but if you take
that second job you're going to make
more money
obviously and it's going to fast forward
your steps
but what would it do to the goal of
getting that uh additional experience
you need
to put yourself in a position where you
get the full-time job doing
what it is you want to do digital
illustrations
i'll be completely honest with you all
ken uh i never studied
digital illustration um and i'm so glad
it didn't happen because i was about to
sign
myself and my mom for a 72 grand back in
2010
for uh exactly and i'm after knowing you
guys and the biggest epsilon
i'm so glad that didn't happen um but it
does leave me
with somewhat of a gap of the knowledge
so basically i'm just going off of
youtube to learn
off of other artists um but the second
job as i was talking to you guys
would be nowhere near again my sweet
spot it would just be a home improvement
uh a job so it would just push me back
further away from
from what you currently speak on yeah
what i'm saying is
it would be one thing if you had to have
the money i would say yes press pause
on the dream job chase but you don't
you're not in that situation you're
actually making progress you're on your
way
um the fact that you self-taught and
you're watching stuff on youtube gets me
all excited because it's like
nobody cares where you went to school
the only question i have because i'm not
as familiar with the digital
illustration field
esteban is it doesn't it sound like to
me that it does require a college degree
it doesn't sound like that but is it is
it favored uh
or are you just learning that it might
be a little bit harder to gain the
actual
basic skills tell me tell me what the
answer is there
well sir uh based on on what i've seen
online on what i've read articles and
whatnot
a lot of artists if i may use the term
are banking um with
not even you know the degree so i've
even questioned myself
i kind of stopped even thinking about
pursuing a degree on that
good yeah condole that's all i needed to
know
i'm so excited here's why folks let me
give this real quick john you jump in
but i want everybody to hear this and
this is really for a lot of parents too
there's this cultural pressure and
you're a big education guy i got to
forget this guy's a dean next to me but
i'm gonna say this to where john doesn't
even disagree
there's a cultural pressure that that
has been put on our parents and our kids
that you've got to go to college
as the rite of passage to success that's
a bunch of hot stinking garbage
here's how you determine if college is
the right decision
is it the only way to get qualified the
only way to get a ticket to the ball
or is it the best way now if it's the
only way in the best way i still want
you to do what our pal anthony o'neil
says and do it the debt free way that's
exactly right but in this situation
esteban is a great example of there's a
lot of people that have gone out and got
a degree in it and probably learned some
really valuable stuff in a classroom i'm
not saying that it's not valuable nor am
i saying it's not helpful
what i'm saying is if you don't need it
and you want to go
a little bit take a little bit longer
maybe
and have to do a lot more you know
self-taught kind of figuring that out
if you're willing to do that you can get
there and he's an example
what this boils down to is do you have
the artistic talent and then can you go
get the experience
that's exactly right i can't hear your
mark i can't imagine somebody sitting
down
at the disney corporation and them
saying man that's an incredible drawing
which we should agree from or the vice
versa hey i went to a fancy pants
university
yeah i'm not the best drawer but check
out this certificate right
they're not going to care about that oh
go ahead
i'm sorry go ahead i'm wondering i feel
like you called us and you already knew
the answer to the call
so why why are you taking this other job
you don't want it it's not going to get
you where you want to go
you don't we could all use extra money
but you don't need the money
why are you putting this on yourself
right um
so i'll be really honest um ever since
covet
uh hit us uh at least my industry um
it's left me with a very small
uh uh or a tight budget um
if i only have like maybe you know maybe
two hundred dollars or you know
150 left after all bills are paid
groceries and whatnot okay and i guess i
became so
infatuated with i gotta get the
babysitters done i gotta run for this
gotta go for the kill and once
there you go brother i got you right
okay so okay so that's a little bit more
information than i had so i'm gonna i'm
gonna
i'm gonna throw a wrinkle to my my
answer
i'm not changing my answer esteban but i
would say
if you were gonna go get a manual labor
job sounds like it was a trade job kind
of a manual labor in the construction
industry did i hear that right
no just a home improvement store oh
sorry okay great great so you're gonna
go work at home improve store here's
what i would do
and if you were planning how many hours
were you planning to work
in your mind part time no i know how
many how many hours
uh 20-25 maybe okay then i would see if
you could get into a place where you can
do 15 or 20
and then what i would do is just lose a
little bit of sleep you can do digital
illustration at two in the morning
or you could do it at five in the
morning so i'm gonna do a little combo
answer
because he doesn't have a lot left in
his budget yeah i'm okay with you
getting that job you know what you need
to do
you can sleep later i take the home
improvement job for the extra doe
gets him into his emergency fund faster
yep gets him into baby step four
faster when you do start sleeping you'll
sleep deeper that's right
and i would but do not quit the digital
illustration journey do you understand
what i'm saying
yes sir you keep going after those
clients they don't care what time of
night or day you're doing it they just
want it delivered am i right
yes sir all right that's the answer do
both both hands and
ken i get this question a lot because i
tell people to take advantage of their
mornings
to make sure people are reading right
working on the things that they actually
love
so all of us have parts of our jobs you
gotta grind out and the most common
question i get is where do you get that
time
i don't understand how this works yeah
from yourself i've started doing an
inventory of my time
you know what if you don't take a 30
minute shower
and you spend approximately zero minutes
scrolling through
instagram and suddenly that's 45 minutes
to an hour you just got back i got to be
honest
i'm a little bit uh curious about the
fact that you referenced a 30 minute
shower is this
is this a normal thing i'm talking about
yeah who takes 30-minute showers people
without kids
really or people with kids who are
hiding from their kids
if you don't spend kelly and james are
both like
are you applying that in order to get
more time back you should just skip
showering because
just do it for three minutes that that's
my normal rhythm is three minutes my
gosh
try a 30 minute shower kick in there
it's awesome yes see
bring a book in there cj i don't want to
look like a human raising but you're
right
you got to steal time from yourself
right take time from yourself get up
earlier
go to bed later you'll be okay because
you got to drive
you got something you're going towards
you can handle a little less sleep for a
season
there you go
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs and the ability to
negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau
chm is here to meet the needs of your
growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
[Music]
the dave ramsey show i'm john dolone
with my good friend ken coleman and
we're taking your calls
on life meaningful work relationships
what do you do
next give us a call at 825-5225 that's
triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's go to heather
and raleigh north carolina
heather what's going on hey oh my gosh i
am so
grateful to be speaking with you two
gentlemen today thank you so much for
taking my call
we are grateful that you called how can
we help
okay so i've got kind of like a a career
slash
life path question um so
i've uh recently in the last six months
took a
new career path and a step up in my
career
and i was able to actually land what i
thought was my
my dream job while i was on furlough
from my previous company
last summer it was a voluntary furlough
because you know i had two small kids
and their daycare was closed and working
from home was impossible
so i just kind of threw out some
linkedin feelers and the new company
found me on there and
um subsequently gave me a 50 000 raise
by taking the new position yeah so i
i went from you know making 70k to 120
000 a year
so it was you know i couldn't pass it
up is that let me ask you this is that
why you thought it was your dream job
just the money or there was actually the
the description of the job and you
looked at it yeah it was more the
description of the job
was kind of you know that that kind of
led me down that oh this is awesome um
so i'm a clinical
scientist in clinical research is what i
do okay and
um the new position put me in the
oncology
research realm which is where i really
wanted to be and
my previous company i was but
yeah but it's turning into kind of um
not quite how they sold it to me uh oh
i hear this a lot yeah and it's the old
miranda yeah
it's yeah there's no such thing as a
free 50 000 raise right
so what's the big what's the best
sticking point what what is really
causing you to go i don't want to do
this
uh well so i'm trying to help them out a
lot more and
increase some efficiencies and i'm
seeing a lot of
data that could be fixed a lot better
but because of the setup i am i work for
one company on i'm contracted to another
you know it's i'm kind of running into a
wall of
you know they don't really want me to do
as much and so i'm kind of getting the
monotonous
tasks versus my previous role where i
was really diving in and had a lot more
stay and was able to make a greater
impact i'm kind of on the
back line yeah they've given you the
heisman stance they're going
thanks but no thanks so what's your
question for us yeah
what's your question for john so my
question is um i
i had a counteroffer from my previous
role at my previous company and so i've
kind of been in talks with them but it
may be
a twenty to thirty thousand dollar pay
cut to go back to that
um well i'm currently 150 000 in debt
so well hold on hold on though so when
you took your current job
john help me if i start mixing this up
my brain is somewhat limited with my
adhd
agreed your current job that you don't
like anymore you thought was your dream
job you got a 50 000
bump did i hear that right yes so you
were making
70. then you said they've counter
offered
and you're going well i'm going to take
a 20 to 30 000 pay cut and you're not
really at all
you're still 20 to 30 up over what you
were right you're going back to where
you were
and you got a nice bump from where you
were so basically the way i'd frame that
john and you tell me this is bad
psychology
but it's like it's really not a cut
you're you're escaping
what is essentially going to become a
professional prison
right and you got a nice little you got
a nice little bonus
it was fun for a few times try something
you got a nice bump to try and you're
going to tell them deuces i'm out
and you come back to where you were and
you're still ahead of where you used to
be that would be the way i'm looking at
it john
psychologically it's going to feel like
somebody took something from you that's
right if you can get past that
and that's where you want to be but
what's the trade-off
so the trade-off heather is i stay where
i am
making 20 to 30 more than if i go back
and i need that extra 20 30 because i've
got 150 grand in debt
uh but i'm miserable so i guess my thing
would be can you get back to the work
you want to do eventually
and can you put up with this monotony
long enough to make it count in your
debt-free journey if you can
i would say i'm fine with you biting the
stick yep but but but
john i mean it's real yeah you keep
going into work every day feeling like
you're just moving a pile of rocks from
one side to the other
that's torture that is hard so what so
what's the real real here heather
yeah that's that's kind of like my hard
thing because you know like i don't want
this
to kind of stop me from the momentum i
had at my previous role because they had
moved me into
manager level i had direct reports and
and they want you back you know it was
yeah and they want me back to do that
and to advance further towards
my eventual plan of being directed
together
whereas here i'm kind of stuck you know
the answer heather you know the answer
i'm going to put you to the heart test
what are you what
you called us because you essentially
said i'm thinking this
you haven't come out and said it heather
what is your heart telling you to do not
your head what's your heart telling you
to
do
to go back to my other company
tell her what she's won john felicia
just go heather
you got it heather heather that's what
john and i agree you should do
don't even think twice about it here's
the deal you're still making
really good money really good money and
you can get out of this debt
and you're going to be on fire because
you're not going to be miserable at work
it's not even close take it and don't
even think twice about it
and you got an opportunity to peek
behind the curtain with
some more money in your pocket yeah and
realize that's not what i want to do
thought it was my dream it's not
yeah you know it's actually becomes a
really nice lesson you learn you got
paid handsomely to learn a valuable
lesson you know a lot of times it looks
like this
i got crushed but i learned a valuable
lesson it's kind of like the oh that
hurt but
i learned a valuable lesson in your case
it's like woo-hoo
i mean well and i realized i learned i
learned something good somebody else
found
reminded themselves or learned had some
more value and we're going to be all
right good for you man all right let's
go to sasha in cleveland ohio sasha
what's going on
hi kim how are you today i'm living the
dream what's going on
oh it's so great to talk to you guys
today um
so i called you about a year and a half
ago and
uh your
inspiring words that gave me the
opportunity to
reach for a job that i honestly didn't
think i
could get and i landed the job and all
right
doubling my income hey yeah i like that
but then 2020 came along
and that dream job was taken from me
they laid off half
this past this past year i'm so sorry
about that
yes so what's your question
so i've decided to try to um go into
business for myself
um so i'm a single mom i
bow down to barely 25 000 a year
just working in small contract case you
know customer service jobs
what's the business that you want what's
the business that you want to go into
um recruiting which is what i was
working in so i was working in
recruiting in hr
oh so you want to start out you want to
do it on your own
yes um i here's my thing from what i
know of the business i can earn for
doing everything i was already doing
okay
okay because that that i'm okay with i
will tell you though
while i believe you my question is what
the timeline is going to look like
because when you start this this
recruiting business
you have to be all in for it to be able
to take care of you
but it might have a ramp up time that
could put you in a really really tough
situation
so my caution to you is and my actual
advice is
no i gave you advice before that you
actually took and did something with and
went and got a job
go back and get another job get stable
again
let's let's build up some money and and
let's get really stable and then go okay
there's a season where i'm where i need
to be financially
and then i'm going to start the
recruiting firm and i'm going to start
the recruiting firm on the side
so that i've got day job money coming in
and then i've got
the dream job the business whatever it's
bringing in i'm not having to live off
of it
takes the pressure off and you're going
to eventually slide
right into owning your own business
please don't go all
in sasha right now as a single mom where
you're in tight tight tight financial
situations it's not the right time
get stable just like you did before
repeat rinse and repeat what i told you
before you did it you know you can do it
i didn't do anything
and then we step into it i love it ken
this is
the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the dave ramsey show i'm john
dalony with my good friend ken coleman
are you trying to find the perfect
valentine's gift
consider this your friendly reminder
good folks in order to make real
progress with your money
you've got to be on the same page as
your spouse you need to work together to
create a budget and a plan that will
help you reach your goals as a team
to help you get on the same page we've
gathered up our best-selling books
budgeting tools and bundles for couples
all in one big sale
so you can save up to 83 percent on the
gifts that will help you reach your
financial goals
and if you're like me here we are in
february
man i me again i made some good uh
new year's resolutions oh yeah some
identity statements here's what i'm
going to be this year
how you doing good good good good but
if you're like me you can grind out 30
days february is the truth teller
right february is when it's man it was
hard to get up this morning and getting
get in the gym
you know why that second and third mile
that first mile when everybody's
cheering you on hey go jump it's all
adrenaline and then you get out there
and you
the crowd's gone the cheering's gone and
you're in mile two three and four
boyle boy is it lonely oh who are you
gonna be so we're putting things on sale
up to 83
on the gifts that will help you reach
your financial goals and you don't want
to miss
our money and marriage livestream event
on february 12th
early bird tickets are only 20 bucks
that's a 10
movie ticket for each of you right now
don't pass over that that's you and
rachel
me and rachel cruz right that's fine
it's gonna be a blast you and stacy of
course are gonna be there
yeah you guys need a lot we need a lot
of help a lot of help a lot of help
a lot of help you're gonna learn how to
have better conversations create deeper
connections we're going to talk about
intimacy make faster progress with your
money we're going to go
there in fact ken i had to get
permission
can we do this oh you did and they said
permission from your wife
no well i didn't do that because i got a
feeling she decided to kind of check
your talk did sit down with miss dolony
and say
yeah all right she's the mrs dr deloney
and i said yeah thinking about talking
about this and she vetoed a few things
rightfully so
good for her this is good for all of us
but let's be honest it is but we're
gonna
go there right um marriages and
relationships are hurting all over the
country so
uh february 12th early bird tickets are
20 bucks right now visit us at
daveramsey.com backslash
backslash store to get your live stream
tickets and valentine's day gifts
hurry the sale is february 14th if stacy
and i come to this
and can you can you pull a few strings a
100
i will i know a guy i can sit on the
front row i know a guy
okay it's a digital event it's all
digital event oh it see
glad i brought that up it's all digital
really you're gonna do it from your
couch
watching this where are you guys uh
gonna be uh live filming
we're gonna be filming all over the
studios it's gonna be a multi-layered
event it's gonna be around the building
lots of fun stuff with me and rachel
cruz james i think what i might do is i
slip in the building that night
undetected and uh i will just show up in
random places during the live event kind
of a where's ken i don't say anything
but i'm just kind of standing in the
back of the set
we got some tight security though i
don't know he'll have to show his
credentials but
that's going to be awesome if you spot
ken there's going to be some free prizes
i think we should do that i'll talk to
dave see what he thinks
100 i don't think he's going to like it
he won't all right let's go to dominic
in wilmington delaware what's up dominic
how are we doing
hey how you doing all right man how can
we help i appreciate it oh you got it
all right
so so right now i am 22 years old
i'm graduating college in may um
i am currently in the process for a
police department uh nearby
excellent um so hopefully i'll be in the
academy right when i graduate
um i have 11k saved up um
i live at home with my parents i have no
bills no debt
i'll have no debt coming out of college
either very cool i'm kind of in this
weird spot where i don't know what to if
i should just leave my money in the bank
or start putting into a roth or
i i just honestly don't know if i should
just save up for a house in the next few
years but
that's where i am right now i have two
parts on two part-time jobs
um and that basically is 25k
a year but i that'll obviously be bumped
in the next six months
from um if i could get hired full time
if you were gonna get accepted into the
to the police academy when would that
start
it would start in may right after i
graduated college yeah if i'm you
and can jump in here if i'm you i just
leave my money in a savings account i'd
leave it alone until i got through
usually the way police academies work is
they give you
a you know 65 75 of a normal salary
until you're out of the academy
at which point then they put you on on
the beat and then they'll move that up
to 85 or 95 percent when you get through
a certain time and that's when you get
into the
the the additional money there and so i
just leave it alone
right i'd leave it alone and get through
the academy
it's hard and it will it will um you
have a lot of studying a lot of run and
a lot of working to do
and then when you get out you can start
making some some different decisions
here how quickly do you start getting
paid
with the um as soon as i start the
account they pay me through the academy
they do okay so that's me but it's a
it's a discounted amount right
yes it would be uh yeah 45
yeah your mama first of all you're
responsible you're not even
you and the word loser don't even belong
in the same universe
i think i'd stay with mom and dad too if
they're not if they are they trying to
kick you out
no not at all i'd stay yeah i i i'm a
fan of that
what i'm not a fan of is the kid who's
using it as an excuse that's right to
not fly a little bird
and i think you are beyond that and
you're an eagle
you're soaring uh i'd stay with mom and
dad to keep those expenses
way low and just keep socking away more
money then once the academy money and
everything starts to feel right you'll
know when it's right
then then i would get out on your own
but right now man i i'd hunker down
yeah i agree i appreciate that you've
got good appreciate it listen i want to
say this
appreciate you man that you want to
serve the public in this way and i know
that you're going to be a great public
servant in this way and
and um i'm proud of you man yeah i
appreciate you man
good for you that means a lot thank you
all right brother good luck man and
graduate strong
yeah let's go to axel in san antonio
texas axel how are we doing
very good thank you for taking my call
you got it man
and being able to speak to you too so i
gotta ask you really quick what's your
last name
uh bettencourt oh such a great name
going for rose here man but that was
good bettencourt's good i love it by the
way he'll have the best name the entire
dave ramsey show today there's no
question about it axel wins the name
award
axel how can we help all right so
this is background i'm 24 right now i
just became that fee last year
i got out the military when i was 22 i
had like 20 000 in death
nice i i started doing the uber eats and
working my job
and just working even on holidays i was
dressed up like at
santa claus on christmas to get those
tips
so finally at 24 as of today i have i
have paid for emergency fund 14 000
dollars
i open my raw off i'm matching my job
psp but now i just don't know what to do
from there
you know like i have the emergency fund
but i don't like
is like for example last month you only
gave me like five dollars you know i
don't know if i should
do something to that or just keep on
changing there you know
[Music]
yeah man so your emergency fund is not a
wealth building tool for you
okay so don't
you don't want to look at it say hey man
how much how much interest are we
earning on this thing um
it's just it's just sitting there that's
the point
the point is to be there when you need
it not to ride any sort of roller
coaster
yeah interest rates are so low you're
never gonna make even when they're
higher than they are now
you're not as john said you're not going
to get a bunch of money on this you look
you walked avery ramsey's baby steps out
you are
you have you're there man so if you've
got your three to six months and let's
say right now that 14 represents three
months if you want to keep juicing that
and get it to six great
that's not a bad thing but if you feel
like three months is enough
uh and you've already started the roth
and it's the 15 percent
uh towards you towards retirement and
then if you feel like you got extra
beyond that
go sit down with a smartvestor pro go to
daveramsey.com and go meet with somebody
in san antonio we've got a bunch of them
down there
and go hey uh in my for my uh for my
situation
as young as i am i'm financially in a
really great place what do i do with
this extra money or what i do here and
just
just keep playing it out you are in
fantastic
fantastic shape my young man here
dressing up as santa claus for some
extra money
he's doing what it takes that's like
next level gazelle intense all right
axel i'm going to tell you something
and this is hard to hear you ready uh-oh
you have been as dave would say gazelle
intense you've been sprinting you saw a
problem
and you have done everything you can to
get rid of that problem
and now you're gonna face something that
most people never reconcile with
that the way to building wealth is not
overly complicated
but it can be boring so you're there
you've got this emergency fund now
you're in baby step four five and six
now you just gotta lock it in and just
keep taking step after step after step
nothing sexy nothing crazy no fireworks
just keep taking the next step and
you're gonna get there
all right like to thank you for joining
us
this hour's in the books ken fun stuff
this has been
the dave ramsey show
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be
intentional about your character you can
have money
and a career you are the hero in your
story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the dave ramsey show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life your work your
relationships and your money
sitting in for dave i am dr john dolone
joined here with my good friend
and colleague ken coleman the host of
the world famous ken coleman show how
are you doing good man
if i was any better i think i'd have to
check around the corner out i don't even
know what that means but
it sounds good yeah i'd be a little
nervous as well oh i see what you're
saying things are good
things are good and you know my general
position on that question is is
you know what it's fine but if it wasn't
you wouldn't want to hear it anyway
nobody really wants an answer to that
how you doing ken
terrible i've got a you know got a boil
in the middle of my back
like really yeah no no we don't want to
hear that just lie to me
yeah that's right which which begs the
question should we ask a different
question
yeah we we are not good you don't really
want you're just a relationship guru we
don't really
want someone to tell us how they're
doing see my problem is i kind of do
on your show you do but not when you're
walking into church hey how you doing
well let me tell you terrible that's
right that's right
so maybe we can just say i hope you're
doing well man it's good to see you
that's the what that's the response hey
good to see you herb it's
good to see you ken i don't know why i
said herb
you know what i will answer it about
anything no i knew you're not hurt i'm
saying i was
it was like it was like a general i like
a herb i like a good herb you like that
i do i like it
yep we have a herb here we do have a
herb he's a smart guy here
really is well we're taking your calls
on life
and relationships money purpose
work all of it anything that's going on
in your heart and mind give us a call
triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five let's go to cynthia in
rochester new york
cynthia good afternoon how are we doing
hi good thanks for taking my call you
bet thanks for calling in how can we
help
um so a little bit of background story
right the
phrase of question i'm 32
i graduated college in 2010 and i
recently decided to take a break
from my six-year relationship with my
boyfriend because
it was kind of getting to the point of
get married or
don't i come with a significant
amount of savings and assets and
it's kind of always been the elephant in
the room in our relationship and i just
want to learn how to get over the fear
and
the i guess insecurity that i have
of not being used or taken advantage of
because of my assets
even though our salaries are pretty
similar like the take-home pay every
month
but it's just like i own my own condo
and um
i have investments and 10 years worth of
retirement funds so
it's just helping me you know come to
terms with that and like letting it be
okay
and knowing that um i'm protecting
myself
so what about this person after six
years
are you still questioning
um like the way you posed that the way
you posed that cynthia was
man here we are six years later and he
wants to get married
and i was like the way you said that it
sounded like three months not six
years right
and you're worried you also said i'm
really worried about being taken
advantage of
is he giving you any reason to feel like
you couldn't trust him
yes and no and we're supposed to talk uh
in two days and i just want to come
prepared and i want to come
with thoughtful answers and questions
and um
you know like every relationship we had
ups and downs and pressures from parents
and his parents were always you know
open arms they
they really uh loved me and my parents
were more taken to stanford
of course look what they're getting look
what he's getting so cynthia
how direct can i be with you very
this relationship will never work if you
think you're superior to him
especially if you think you're superior
to him because of
assets because of things you have in
your bank account
i think one of the great cultural curses
of the modern world
is that we have distilled down the
question what are you worth
to a financial number and we
look at like we say hey what are you
worth man that's a number the answer to
the question what are you worth
is never a number and so if you're
sitting across
a table at a nice restaurant if you're
sitting on the couch next to
somebody you have known and loved and
walked alongside the ups and downs of
six years
and you think i'm still better than you
i still have more money than you then
honey don't do this to him
don't yeah if you were going to enter
this relationship and say we are all in
and we're going to co-create a future
together i'm bringing this
he's bringing that we're going to create
this together
awesome cynthia i asked you earlier if
he had done
something to make you feel like you
could not trust him you said yes and no
i wanna i mean you don't have to bear
all the details here but
you gotta address the yes part whatever
he has done that has make
made you lose trust in him has got to be
addressed between the two of you and if
not
uh just between the two also with a
counselor right john i mean
what is it can't leave that how is it
well i think it's coming from mom and
dad but
what has he done that makes you not
trust him
um there was an episode where he
uh cooked with drugs so that was a big
red flag for me
so that's not a that's not an asset
thing that's a hey
i'm that's a poor judge i don't want to
be married to someone
right and i i think i was using the
money as an excuse honestly in my career
yeah the same thing
yeah what is that sweetheart you know
you know
you know money you know you can marry a
homeless man down the street it
shouldn't matter
if he treats you well and he makes you
feel you know what teeth and calm
there you go cynthia okay you know on
top of financial security i wasn't
getting that emotional security
so so so can i can i be direct with you
again
cynthia can i be direct again sure
you've got permission to walk away yeah
you're worth somebody's gonna love you
and somebody that's
um gonna share values with you and
that's gonna keep you safe and keep you
connected and
treat you like you're a valuable special
extraordinary human being regardless of
your finances
and so it's um you have permission to
walk away
and you're going to feel like i put six
years into this thing you you're 32 now
you think
back to what when you were 26
you just met and you were in love and
this guy's funny and cool and all that
and now you look up and you're 32 you're
not married you're making your way and
you want to be connected and you are now
coming to the honest truth
this isn't the guy you've got permission
to walk away cynthia you just gave
yourself the truth that i think you
called us for and that was you said
i was using the money stuff as an excuse
the reality is
he wasn't giving you the emotional
security that you long for that you
deserve and also this drug thing wasn't
an episode either we don't need to break
that down but there's a lot of
trust issues here and i i i
yeah you don't need to feel guilty at
all
you you need to feel cherished you need
to feel
challenged wanted and challenged this is
a partnership marriage is no
joke um you guys can have a talk
but i would have walked away power he
needs to know that you mean business
and that's not financial related not
judgment related
it's i'm worth this that's right
good for you cynthia i know that's a
hard conversation after six years
go into it boldly humbly be honest you
don't need excuses
tell the truth and you deserve to be
loved
this is the dave ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help get you there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
[Music]
this is the dave ramsey show i'm john
doloni joined by my good friend and
ramsay personality ken coleman
we're taking your calls on life and work
and relationships and money
everything anything that's going on in
your heart and mind give us a shout
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go to michael
in wood bridge virginia michael what's
going on brother how can we help
hey ken how you doing i'm living the
dream
how can we help yeah oh i'm living the
dream too
oh that's good well hey i want to say
thank you and everybody on dave ramsey's
team
for what you guys teach and the stuff
you guys offer you guys do a great job
of that
i'm a huge fan uh i am working through
the baby steps i have baby step one all
done we're on baby step two we're
almost to the halfway point of baby step
two and we're just chucking away
debt good um i just had a life situation
uh
come up that's kind of a big change for
me i've been living with my parents for
quite some time now
and this past december i ended up
getting
a uh an apartment from somebody
that i go to church with and um
the only issue that i've just been
having is
i've already signed the lease i've made
the security deposit on it
but i've only paid like a small portion
of the uh
rent and i haven't been able to pay
anymore because i haven't been able to
live and
my mom and dad think it's a waste of
money if i
just pay rent and i'm not living in the
place so
just kind of wanted to get your guys
guidance as to
am i being ripped off or should i just
you know be patient and
have them make sure everything's ready
for the apartment
uh there's a lot here yeah kind of back
up a second when you i want to start
with you said
i've i've paid some of the security
deposit
some of the rent but uh i haven't paid
any more because i haven't been able to
live i
i got stuck there what does that mean
what's your financial situation right
now
so my financial situation is the next
there's one other bill that i'm adding
on to my budget
which is uh rent and where i'll be
renting
is it includes everything in utilities
except
internet i've already got a separate
payment for that
but i've already paid the security
deposit i've already signed the
rental agreement um for the lease
but um i haven't been able to fully move
in yet
why because they're still because there
there was something with the water line
that was going on that they didn't
expect to have
happen and so they're trying to fix that
and everything
if you sign the lease for a place to
live and they're not giving you a place
to live
they're in breach of the lease yeah and
so either they find you a new place
or they let you out of the lease or they
reduce the amount that you owe them on
this lease
but it's it's super super simple yeah
and
you walk straight into the office and
say i need a place to live on the agreed
date at the agreed price
and you said this place there's a water
issue so where am i going to
live yeah you need to know you need to
know what this water line you don't even
know what it is that would freak me out
what do you mean you got a water line
problem i'm going to need like a four
page report with a
you know with a with a powerpoint
presentation i i just think you call
them and go hey
let's uh i think john gave you great
advice
if if that's what you're asking i mean i
would not move fully into this thing
right now
um i yeah and that's what i'm trying to
do is like be
patient with them trying to get this
fixed out and then trying to work
something out with the rent
i just want to make sure just get your
guys advice to make sure i'm not getting
ripped off or not
well if you've given them a security
deposit for a place
that they said you were going to live in
on a certain day and a place isn't ready
then yes you're getting ripped off
now okay be a person of respect and
dignity
don't be a jerk and walk in and not not
saying that you will
but it's easy to get self-righteous and
indignant in these kind of moments
people are
usually doing the best they can with the
tools they got
do this in person tell somebody you want
to meet with them and say hey look we
signed this lease
and i was ready to move and i know that
you like you said you're a friend from
church you're helping me out
but i need to know if we're going to
move or not and i need to get my deposit
back if we're not going to be moving
because i got to find a place to live
asap and hopefully they'll find another
apartment for you or they'll let you
know like
they'll have the 17-page
report due that ken needs and um for the
water issue and then they'll get you
squared away
but don't avoid a conversation don't get
your heart rate up if you've never
talked to the person
and just go straight in and solve this
problem directly yeah i think there's a
time to be patient i think now is the
time to be persistent
then once we get all the answers then we
can be patient but i don't have enough
details right now
for me to be patient yeah yeah yeah
especially if i've already put my money
on the line there
right all right let's go to jessica in
cincinnati ohio
jessica what's going on hi thanks so
much for having me
um i have kind of a complicated uh
question
and like life direction question i think
you guys can help me with but all right
bring it on
so so i'm a nurse um
by trade i've been a nurse about 17
years and about four years ago
i decided to go optional and
to be a stay at home mom and of course
with the pandemic
there's been opportunity for me to kind
of like contractually
like get back in and be at the bedside
again and i'm making
really awesome money uh which is such a
huge blessing because my husband and i
have been
like dave esque for a while so we're
really we got a bigger shovel to get out
of our debt so and actually today we're
paying off our second car so
congratulations that's awesome yeah yeah
it feels so good
so the thing about it is is um
i can still like continue on for like
who knows how long right in this
um this bedside nursing where we're
making
lots of money because of the pandemic
which is awesome but it's actually not
really
like my passion anymore i have a totally
different
like direction that i've been kind of
like side hustling in the culinary world
and i love that so i don't know um
trying to figure out like what to do
with my life uh when i grow up even
though i'm 38.
um just do i keep pursuing like the
culinary stuff
or should i stick with this you know
this nursing for a little bit longer and
get a little bit keep that big shovel um
i'm just not really sure i'm praying
about it and i just i really just need
some
some design direction as well all right
you ready here we go
this is a you said this you said this
was a complicated question
and it's really it's not super nice
i got two simple answers you ready i
want you to write this down because this
is so simple i'm ready i have pen and
paper
i'm ready the answer is yes
and yes you keep
okay stay with the bedside nursing
because of the huge shovel that it is
providing for you
you add all that to this aggressive get
debt-free plan that you and your hubs
are on right you just keep crushing it
momentum you've already started this
culinary pursuit on the side anyway
so it's not like you don't have the time
you can do it keep doing the culinary
thing keep testing it keep getting
better at it
scale it a little bit or if you have to
just hold steady
and then when you get that emergency
fund paid off
you know and then i think that's when
you go all right let's reassess
do i now walk away from nursing but i
think this is
a really easy decision because i think
it takes the pressure off of the dream
this oh wow think about this
you are pursuing this dream this
culinary side hustle
and you're doing it in a non-pressure
field environment you're not relying on
it to pay off debt
you're not relying on it to pay the
bills it's gravy right now am i right
yes absolutely so here's the deal
oh that's the word that's the magic
here's why here's why oh this is so
exciting listen
most entrepreneurs start a business
and they put all their eggs in the
basket and it creates all kinds of
stress
it makes them lose their patience and
right now you're in a place where you
can
persist and be patient and you got a
great day job
and you and the hubs are rocking you're
paying off debt and we're seeing the
dream
and you're going to get to a point in
the very near future where this day job
is going to actually possibly fund
an expansion of the dream job so i think
you will be the one to determine when
you leave the bedside nursing
but right now do both you already have
been
yes and yes i wish that i had some
wisdom on top of that but i think that's
awesome we know john sometimes i just
really nailed it
and that was that time that was about us
that was
that was just about as good of an answer
as she could have possibly hoped for you
were the guy yes and yes somebody you
are dating
and as you were about to drive off you
rolled the window down and said
that was an amazing date just we all
needed to acknowledge that was an
amazing date and i love that about you
ken coleman
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters
with easy online ordering free shipping
and a guaranteed perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
blinds.com's 100 satisfaction guarantee
means even if you mismeasure or pick the
wrong color they'll remake your blinds
for free
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save
even more use promo code ramsay to get
the best deal
rules and restrictions apply john
today's question comes from daniel in
california he writes i've worked
at my current job for almost five years
since the end of my second year
my manager has been teasing me with a
promotion by saying
promotion pending on my annual reviews i
sent him an email late last year asking
what i needed to
do before i would be eligible for a
promotion and all he said was
i would be eligible january 2021 january
is come and gone and still no word what
is the best and most respectful way to
go about asking for a promotion
well uh normally john what i would tell
folks is don't ask for a promotion don't
ask for a pay raise ask for a growth
plan
where you sit down with your leader and
you say hey i want more
yep and i know more means
i want to get better i want to be more
valuable to the organization so
uh what are some areas that you you see
that i could improve what are some
additional skills
or training that you think that if i got
that makes me a
a better a little bit more valuable in
the current role
or or ready for others and then
um what does a growth plan look like in
the organization if we measure
my work do we have a key results area
like we do at ramsey solutions where we
all have a one page document this is a
win for john delaney this is a win for
ken coleman is what i need to do
is what i'm expected to do and here's
the results we need to create that with
a leader that's the growth plan and when
we do that it becomes a very natural
progression into if i grow my
responsibility and my
influence then my income comes with that
so i want to grow professionally and i
want to grow financially
it doesn't put the leader um on a
defensive tilt
as is when you go and say i want to talk
about a raise but based on this question
folks
um this has already been talked about
this guy's been writing promotion
pending on i kind of don't like that
i don't either that irritates me hunt
man that's switzerland dude you gotta
make a call
it's also kind of a mean little carrot
to dangle out in front of somebody just
because we're adults doesn't mean we
aren't
still that little kid that says do i
matter right do you see me that's what
workers long to know
that's what we all long to know so in
this situation because he said january
2021
and no word i'm having a meeting with
him scheduled a meeting hey yep here's
the history of what we've discussed
i want to be here i want to be more
valuable i want to grow i want to
do all the things i've got dreams and
listen if if this isn't
where you see that being possible just
let me know yeah
i'm down with it but we've talked about
and talked about talked about it
what does that look like for me to be
able to get the promotion can we put a
plan together
because here's what's happened when you
talk promotion with a leader who isn't
ready to deliver on it it's easy for
them to punt
yeah they kick the can down they'll go
oh we'll talk about it later no no
there's no talking about it
what we say now is can we sit together
schedule a meeting can we do it right
now if not right now can we schedule a
meeting
in the next week to actually
put on paper a growth plan that would
allow me to not just get promoted but
also to begin to make more money
if the answer gets kicked down the road
then then you know what it's time for
adios out there you go i'm looking
somewhere else
and i never give advice to just jump off
a cliff
get something else the minute you got
the contract or you got the signed deal
on something else then you walk in and
say
it's been great i'm out so tell me if
you hear this on your show a lot ken
um in the past i've experienced this
i've been guilty of this
and i've led big teams that have
experienced this
a promotion or a raise should be
reflective of
this journey of work right what is your
your value to this company we need you
we want to recognize you we want to
increase your scope here but we've
turned
promotion into a destination and what i
see people's with their mental health is
if i can just get to be associate
director my life's going gonna be okay
if i can go from 50 to 57 000 and my
problems are gone
and it never works that way
and i i don't know if you hear this on
your show i love the way you twisted
that because
you're asking somebody what really is
important which is how do i get
more outstanding at this work how do i
help our downstream customer
which is the only thing that matters
here right how do i help them
even more and on the way
you're gonna get promoted the money's
gonna take care of itself because you
become such an asset but the
the focus is on the work and not this
imaginary
not true destination that's supposed to
heal you right so glad you said that so
you said destination and i had a thought
that might get to in a second i gotta
write it down so i don't forget it okay
so i'm a fan of meritocracy okay
so is dave right now we're getting
political yes no see he thinks that's
political
it's not political right meritocracy
just simply means this is merit-based
that's what that's what a workplace
should be
merit-based meaning i am delivering
results
and i am delivering good results and i'm
continuing to deliver great results
and as i add value to the organization
then they should in return reward me
well that's not near as fun as i was
thinking i agree with you yep okay so
here's my point though a lot of people
not only i thought was a great point you
made that a lot of people think that the
promotion is the destination oh i'm
going to be better i'm going to feel
better about myself and all that we know
that's hollow you're not
however a lot of people i'm going to
step on some toes right now so everybody
get ready
and a lot of young people and this is a
function of age so don't pick on
millennials and mosaics here you were
like this too you xers and boomers so
shut up
but we think that a promotion it's
become an
expectation i've been here 18 months
been here a year
where's my meeting where's the meeting
i've been here a year that's right
uh i've only been late three times uh
i've not punched a co-worker
um i have done everything you asked me
to do
it's time for a raise let me tell you
something this is that's a hundred
percent
this is absolutely right i hear this all
the time i get these calls from young
people hey ken listen um
i need to ask you a question about
asking for a raise i get this call
every week on the ken coleman show and i
say okay well
tell me tell me what's your background
well i've been there a year oh
okay instead of
i'm crushing it i've developed such a
rapport yeah
with these customers they keep coming
back they want to know how my kids are
doing they
i want to know how their families do it
right i'm adding value yeah it's
time i wanted to unpack that other side
of it and john's right
don't make your promotion this
destination and also don't allow it to
become an expectation
here's the point this is a meritocracy
folks it just is work is a meritocracy
and sometimes
it's a really crappy one yep that's why
people leave
companies they don't leave companies
they leave leaders yeah and if a leader
won't recognize an
individual because we all long to be
seen
yes this is a core human need do you see
me do you notice me
and we want to add value not just to the
company but we want to see our work
make a difference in the lives of others
that's why i call it meaningful work
that's what we all along for so
in this situation if you've got to put
your leader who may be really kind of
not good at this
at ramsey solutions everybody's got that
kris we know what is expected of us
we know how we're measuring results
against
the expectations those are two key
things that are very different folks
and and so if leaders don't do that for
you got to sit down with them and don't
put them on tilt and on defense and go
hey i've been here about a year i'd like
to talk about a race
uh they're not even ready for that so
what do they do
kick the can down the road we'll talk
about it and they're going i don't know
i don't know what to do yeah this guy i
think that's what's going on
in that question and so you've got to
sit down with them and go hey i just i
want to be here i want to grow
let them see your human side because
everybody has that same feeling i want
to grow
but i want to add value first tell me
where i can get better
yes how do i help this customer how do i
help their
family how do i help like the roofer
that is helping yeah how do i help
protect this guy welcome
even talk about how you can grow value
you want to provide
and after you do that then you can go
and i'd like to measure that
because what you're saying is i want to
be accountable how are we going to
measure me
because i believe in me and i believe if
we measure me
we're going to see the results and so
i'm saying when we measure me what's the
compensation tied to the output
but let's start with value let's start
with excellence and here's the real
genius behind this idea if you bring
your leader in that way and they're
semi-healthy or healthy
they're gonna jump on that and now
they've got input they feel like it's
their idea
of course and leaders if you've got
somebody in your organization
that is adding value call them in today
and look them in the eye and say you're
adding value thank you we're gonna
figure out how to help you out too
don't let that be one-sided we're
telling the kids to
stop with the hey i've been here four
months with my raise
leaders across the country got to step
up too and recognize value
don't just pull them into your office
and tell them tell them in front of
their co-workers yeah
that's even better this is the dave
ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the dave ramsey's show i'm john
delony with my good friend ken coleman
we are taking your calls on life and
work and money
give us a shout at triple eight 825 5225
let's go to adam in cincinnati adam how
are we doing man
hey i'm good how are you doing guys very
very good how can we help
so um my wife and i recently finished
paying off
all of our consumer debt except for our
mortgage and at the end of this month
we're gonna have our
three months of uh emergency fund very
cool man
way to go thank you how's that feel
i thought um that's kind of where i'm
calling so
i thought at this point i would feel
more of a sense of accomplishment
but i almost feel like i've checked one
box and i'm on to the next block of
trying to pay off the mortgage early
is that kind of normal does it take you
some time to kind of
re-equilibrate i don't know if that's a
word re-equilibrate a little bit and
just
you know be able to enjoy the
accomplishments that you've had after
being that in that gazelle mindset for a
while i'm just curious
john i want john let to john tackle that
the psychologist here but i'm just
curious did you all celebrate in any way
uh no we haven't not like not even like
a nice dinner to say man we just paid
off our debt
no we haven't yeah you've really
adam you gotta kind of been yeah
that's kind of been crazy you know
it's been an up and down describe that
for me
because i think there's something else
here when you say my life's been crazy
what else do you mean
so like about a year after we started
the process
i left teaching and went back to school
um
at night while also working and then she
got an engineering degree
so for like four years i was busting
you know 90 hours a week between work
and school my wife was working 50 to 60
hours a week
we had our first kid about two weeks
after i started going back to school
and then a couple years ago i got my
promotion once i started my
career in engineering my wife left her
job so we took like a 25 000
pay cut about three weeks after we moved
we found out we were unexpectedly
pregnant with our second child
um when i got a promotion last year
another promotion last year in july
my wife started working part-time again
so we're
back to making almost 100 000 a year and
it's just been life has been crazy
yeah it's been a high speed role taking
time to focus on ourselves we've just
been trying to
you know keep our head you know above
water and just
trying to make sure we had a little all
right adam you just said it brother
i gotta ask a question on behalf of adam
love it so adam you've given us
i gotta ask john is he in a situation i
don't know what you call this
but see a situation where he's been
biting the stick so long his jaw's
locked and he doesn't know how to just
let off that stick
well you can here's the thing
you can be in survival mode for so long
yeah that you start creating new
environments for yourself that you've
got to survive
that's a better way of saying and then
the then you start to get to the end of
that tunnel and then we are
going in to survive something else right
and adam here's what's going to happen
and you know this so i'm just saying it
for everybody listening
because you're not the only person who's
experienced this you're one of the few
people with the courage enough to call
it out
you're going to look up brother and
you're going to be 35 or 40
and your kids are going to be in their
late teens and you're going to have run
from one thing to another thing to
another thing to another thing
you're going to look across the kitchen
table you're not going to really know
your wife
your kids are going to be staring at
their phones they're not going to want
to talk to you
and you're gonna realize i spent all of
my life in gazelle
intensity and i missed it and so here's
the thing
you know you just said it here and you
know
what the deal is the deal is man you
have had a
crazy time the last couple of years
going back to school
changing life direction changing purpose
uh
your wife is going running and gunning
oh and you bring a kid in
and so that's just a hurricane blizzard
that just hits your house
and then whoa surprise we got another
one on the way
we're not sleeping here we go no sleep
no
it's all chaos yeah here's what i want
you to do adam will you do me a favor
yeah you got a pin you're an engineer
you don't even need a pen
all right here we go ready number one
this weekend you're gonna take your wife
on a date i don't care how much it cost
i don't care if you can't find child
care figure it out okay
your kids are one and three they'll be
fine i'm just kidding don't do that
right so you're gonna take your wife on
a date and i want her to get dressed up
i want you to get dressed up
i want you to start the date by opening
her car door and i want you to
re-imagine
re-falling in love with your wife
starting this weekend
and you're going to date her again and
you're going to start there because that
is the most important relationship
in your life and this weekend is going
to be about
celebrating this extraordinary
accomplishment of becoming debt free
except for your mortgage
you're going to have an awesome time
dreaming together about what life will
be like when you pay the mortgage off
you're going to
say that start that dream conversation
at that nice dinner that's right start
that dream and by the way buy her
something nice not just
not just don't you just iron your shirt
dude put on some khakis whatever dress
up is
buy her something nice do something
great you can afford it bro you're the
engineer this isn't going to make sense
in any of your dumb little spreadsheets
i'm giving you permission
this weekend you re-fall in love with
your wife intentionally and on purpose
okay and then you're going to talk about
what how are we how we taking care of
our kids what's the trajectory of our
kids
what kind of house do we want to have
you're going to re-learn how to breathe
and then you're going to write down
together what are ways we're going to
insert into our lives on a regular thing
we got to practice this and they don't
tell you this in marriage therapy and
they should shame on them
you got to practice intimacy you got to
practice being connected you got to
practice remaining in love
and i tell you what ken titanic lied to
us the notebook lied to us romeo and
juliet lied to us what
we just walk into a room and we're like
there she is
and i don't have any more work to do
we're just gonna be in love
we're gonna have two kids seven kids
change jobs get laid off have
have a have a pandemic or two have a
chaotic election cycle where i don't
know you believe that i believe it all
that's going to be okay because we see
each other and we're in love
and that's not how it works and
we've been told that there is external
solutions to
internal holes right there is and i and
and
that's a lie it's a lie and you just
gave some beautiful advice
i'm just gonna i'm just gonna add that
um one of the things that irritates me
about our world that we live in this
performance
based because everybody's looking at us
and and it irritates me when i see these
football coaches or basketball coach
they win a national championship and
and you know oh the next day the next
day we started for next season and i
always go
this is just so stupid why don't you go
on a freaking cruise
and celebrate the fact that you worked
your butt off
you fought for everything you had to win
and this is what's going on here adam
worked his butt off he and his wife
fought and clawed to get debt free
now they want to pay the house off well
great there's a reason why dave by the
way put to pay the house off
at the end of the baby steps it's six
yeah there's a reason it's hard
and it takes a while it does and so we
cannot live
all the time in this fight claw
scratches just it's not who we are
and so when you do what this couple has
done folks
celebrate it now that doesn't mean you
go crazy but
celebrate it and not just celebrate it
with stuff
celebrate it emotionally mark the moment
i love the idea of going to dinner or
maybe go on a walk and sit there maybe
sit by a lake
and just hold hands and throw rocks in
there and go wow do you remember when we
did this remember we ate mac and cheese
for seven straight days or whatever
or here's mark the moment it's a mile
marker
as we've been sprinting for the last two
years here's ten
things i've discovered i love about you
yes but you don't even know here they
are that's weird you know why
because any man or woman who's ever
accomplished anything significant and by
the way
when you folks who listen and watch the
show you've gotten debt free or you're
close
you've done something significant you're
doing something that's going to be this
is nothing to do with notoriety and fame
and power
i'm saying anything that is a
significant accomplishment
you talk to anybody after the fact
there's a euphoric state at first kind
of like oh my gosh i typically did it we
did it you know it's kind of like is
this really happening
and then you realize something you're
the same person you were before the
accomplishment there's the letdown right
well it might be it's not so much to let
down neutralizing it's that it's like
wait a second i'm still the same guy
i'll tell a story on that maybe maybe
some other time on the show together but
here's the point
is that when we get there we realize
wait a second it was about the journey
to this moment that made it euphoric
it wasn't about the status that i'm
debt-free it's that what i did and
who we became on the journey it's the
journey not the destination
adam we're proud of you good job you be
proud of you
yes love your wife let her love you
celebrate love those two little kids
and we fall in love together this
weekend we're excited for you brother
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be
intentional about your character you can
have money
and a career you are the hero in your
story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the dave ramsey show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life
your work your purpose and your money
sitting in for dave i'm dr john deloney
joined here with my good friend and
fellow ramsey personality
ken coleman we are taking your calls on
anything
anything going on in your heart in your
mind in your home
in your relationships at work in the
mirror
give us a call triple eight eight two
five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five
let's go to lisa in charlotte north
carolina lisa what's going on how can we
help
hey good afternoon hope you guys are
well and also with you
yeah i am calling today to um just get
some insight
from you dr delany and um your thoughts
of the current i hate to say trend
but i question if it's a trend of
prevalence
to label teenagers with anxiety
specifically girls so um do you have a
particular story
yeah there you go so what's going on
here
yeah we've got a senior girl who had um
basically disappointment and sadness
when they did not go back to school in
the fall
and you know you acknowledge it and i
mean how can you not
um but has developed into
the point where she asked for counseling
so okay you go
and the counselors
are very eager to label anxiety
and my husband and i we you know we
question
is it is it disappointment is it
situational stress
is it things that we view more as
life moments just life yeah versus
mental health
label kind of thing and it's interesting
talking with other moms
the prevalence associated
whether it's stereotyping or are we not
teaching
our kids life moment yeah
um so i just wanted some insight on it
and and
you know how you how you view that yeah
lisa you uh
you just made in one call you pushed
most every button i have
and i'm a pretty laid back guy and you
pushed them all so i'm gonna just put it
all out there
can't you hop in at any point by putting
me over
i'm gonna referee i'll throw a flag if
it gets out of hand so
here's the thing a couple of different
things and i'm saying this
i've worked with thousands of high
school and college kids over the last
almost two decades 16 17 years i don't
even know how long
um we have a culture that has
over pathologized discomfort
we are quick to label anything like you
mentioned you said it perfectly any life
situation so i'll give you an example
i can't tell you how many kids freshman
sophomore in college would come into my
office heartbroken
weeping real true deep pain
it's real it hurts and they'd say hey
i'm depressed i've got anxiety and i'd
say what's going on and they say well
my dad just moved out my parents are
getting divorced
my granddad died and often i would say
thank you for sharing that i don't want
you to walk around saying you're
depressed you're sad and you're supposed
to be sad because your parents are
getting divorced
because you lost a dear grandparent
and so we are obsessed with putting a
label on discomfort as though it's
something we
can um anesthetize ourselves to that we
have somehow figured out this perfect
pain-free life it doesn't
exist it's not real so i'm a hundred
percent with you on that i think we over
label kids i think kids who have been
stuck at home and realized oh my gosh
i'm not going back to school
i can't see my friends i'm not going to
get real human interaction
absolutely it's devastating and we need
to sit with him
and not um not brush it over oh shake it
off in my date that's not helpful right
let that those feelings be real and
a year into sitting at home when
our kids haven't seen anybody those
anxiety alarms
get louder and louder right because
these kids are disconnected
they're trying to learn in an
environment if you look at maslow's
hierarchy
they're not safe they're not connected
we've got parents who are fighting and
yelling in the home or they are
trying to figure out how to navigate
their own work situations and financial
situation all that
so the anxiety alarms are real and then
on top of all that we've got a culture
that says
that the insurance companies drive these
counseling sessions and say
if there's not a diagnostic we're not
helping you pay for this
so counselors i my heart is for the with
them too they are forced into a
situation this is psychologists and
counselors and marriage and family
therapist social workers everybody
that they don't get paid unless they
give you a
have a label right so everybody's hemmed
in on this thing
and then there's a fourth complexity
which is sometimes it's helpful to name
the dragon
sometimes there is some peace looking at
a kid saying hey you're not broken
your body's doing exactly what it's
supposed to do when you find yourself
alone and scared and frustrated and
angry
it sounds the alarms and that's what
anxiety is there
is a time and a place for a quote
unquote anxiety diagnosis
but i am real real slow to do that
real slow to do that every good
counselor that i know
is real slow to do that and is
real open to talking through especially
in your situation where you've got a
minor
that you should be involved in those
conversations too i am terrified of 20
years from now
what it's going to look like with all
these young people who have these
medical charts
much of it digitized with these mental
health diagnostics
when they try to go get a job when they
try to get health insurance when they
try to get
life insurance when they try to get
militaries to fill in the blank
right so i'm with you what i'll tell you
is this
even with an anxiety diagnosis as a mom
or a dad
unless i get some very clear guidance
from a therapist that says
your kids got some severe pathology your
kid is really struggling and it needs
some
um intervention that's more than a
regular counselor can offer
i'm going to handle it the same way i'm
going to be over
intentional about connecting with my kid
i'm going to be over intentional about
listening walking alongside um
people laugh and i get email after email
about i thought you were crazy and this
super works
um putting my hands on their on their
hands on their face looking them in the
eye and making sure they know that i
love them
figuring out ways that i can they can be
around people their own age if we've got
to do outside events depending on where
we live
or we have to do them safely whatever
that looks like but going out of our
ways to
curate connection with these kids
because their anxiety alarms are real
but i don't think it's a forever label
that needs to be attached to them
right like a like a tattoo right ken
what do you think
i think what you said is absolutely
right and i think that
just like anything if you go to a doctor
many times you'll get a second opinion
and i think that parents need to feel
okay sometimes trusting their
guts you know we know from a lot of
research that when somebody trusts their
gut it's actually their head as well
just some good old common sense and as a
parent i've got three teens
there are times where i've had to sit
with it for a little bit
and i go wait a second if i remove my
emotions and i use my common sense
um i'm gonna give my kid a second
opinion i'm gonna love on him and i'll
just mention this because this is how we
roll
at the coleman house i found that the
biggest breakthroughs come when we pray
and we pray without ceasing we just pray
and we pray and we pray and we don't
stop praying
uh i think that's the wonder drug well i
i appreciate your heart lisa
your kid's not well wimp your kid's not
uh weakling
she's gonna be fine your kid's not
broken forever either get her connected
and stay connected
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
cliff and i joined christian healthcare
ministries because we really like the
concept of
christians sharing each other's burdens
and we really experienced that firsthand
when cliff
was diagnosed with heart disease it was
just such
a relief to know that financial burden
was going to be taken care of
chm is the original and longest serving
health cost
sharing ministry get started today and
check us out at
chministries.org
[Music]
so
[Music]
do you feel like you'll always be stuck
paying off debt
or that you'll never have extra money to
save and spend
how you want it doesn't have to be that
way
and i'm talking to you yes you who's
just vacuuming and you got your
headphones in right now
or you're driving across the country in
a long-haul truck
or you're just scrolling through youtube
i'm talking to you it doesn't
have to be that way you have to believe
that you can get rid of this debt and
take control of your money
because you can and it's not going to
take as long as you think i've got so
much in debt i'm so much into
i know and we've talked to millions of
people
with ramsay plus we'll kick off we'll
kick you off with 90 days of guided help
so you can put more of your money back
in your bank account you'll learn
practical ways to get small
consistent wins that add up to big
results and better habits
and that means you'll get where you want
to be faster
debt free and spending your money get
this
without worry another way to say that is
with peace this year you can make more
progress
on your debt and saving than you ever
have get ramsay plus and start living
the life you want
faster to start ramsey plus get this for
free text trial to 33789
that's trial t-r-i-a-l-33789
all right let's go to chris in dayton
ohio chris what's up how are we doing
hello hey chris hey how you doing
i'm doing outstanding brother how can we
help uh
got a quick uh just some advice
questions so
um i uh 33
uh a wife and three kids and we
bought my parents farm last january
okay and uh to operating
small uh fruit and vegetable farm about
20 acres here
um i've been transitioning
we rented the farm from them for a few
years and we finally bought it
i've been transitioning from working a
regular job as a diesel mechanic
to being self-employed for probably
about three years now
and last year i
went full time on the farm and this fall
i've been doing like remodeling stuff
so my question is um
i'm trying to figure out if uh
like i'm trying to figure out
so my dad sold me the property for 350
000.
it's probably worth about 450 to
500 probably so he gave you a pretty
good deal on it
right so i have some equity in the
property okay but i feel like i'm
working my butt off just to try and stay
afloat here so
i'm trying to find out if i should try a
land contract also
when you say stay afloat when you say
stay afloat you're running the farm and
the money the farm is making
isn't covering your bills well it does
during the summer time but i have to do
something in the fall which is fine i
don't have a problem doing that but
and this is like my passion and the only
reason that i bought it is because
i got a really good deal on it and my
dad was going to sell the farm
which i grew up on so um
i didn't want it to be gone you know so
let me ask you
again let me ask you this um during the
summer when it's paying the bills does
it also throw off enough profit to
to pay the bills for the whole year on
the farm are you having to do this
remodeling to help pay the bills
during the off season no the farm pays
for
its own operating costs and pays us
during the summer
months that's fantastic now let me ask
you this when i do the remodeling none
of my remodeling money goes
to the farm only goes to painter bills
great and
does that include you paying down the
mortgage on it
yes so you called us for a reason i'm
not quite sure what
what are you having doubts about you
sound like you're really thinking
through this hit me
what do you what do you want us to speak
to um
so i'm just trying to
find out like what would you do in my
situation like
um i'm working really hard should i just
and so here's the thing so we've kind of
done
the daisy rmd stuff on and off we've
never really stuck with it okay
so i guess my question is do i just stay
with this farm
and really stick to the budget and all
the baby steps
and make this happen or do i try and get
out of this and get a job
i can get a good paying job and get a
small house and like save money really
fast
so chris did you buy this thing
because it tugged at your heartstrings
because you had fond memories of this
place
and now that you're now you're doing it
full-time you're looking at
hey i got 30 more years of this and i'm
i just don't like it it's not what i
want to be doing
have you had a moment of clarity and
honesty no he loves it he said it was
his passion
you love this yeah this is what i want
to do how much debt let's do a real
quick analysis how much debt do you have
besides the home besides the farm don't
don't give me the farm
i have 20 000 uh credit card and
unsecured loan that that's it
that's it 20 000. and you said you're
off and on so you understand and you
have at times
had momentum you've been working the
baby steps you know what to do on the
debt snowball correct
right um and you've got the farmers
throwing off money to be able to pay you
and pay its mortgage uh and all the
expenses
i i don't see it being a millstone i
don't see this being a problem
i think during the off season you're
getting with it you've already been
working real hard as a farmer
i don't know anybody works harder than a
farmer no so i'd be getting after it
right now maybe a second remodeling job
maybe a better paying job
in the off season crush the 20 000 and
then go all in on the farm
unless i'm missing something i think you
will regret
selling the farm okay
and i also i also don't know again i
i coming from a farming community i
don't know many farmers
and i i can be way wrong i don't know
many farmers personally that do not also
have
something that they're doing in the off
season
right yeah but i have no problem doing
that i mean is that land worth a lot
whether it's a farm or not um
as farm ground it's it's worth a decent
amount in our area yeah
about ten thousand an acre okay because
what i'm saying what i'm thinking
through is is what happens if that
particular
you know because farming has been hit
hard pretty you know pretty hard by some
of the economic policies you know
we're kind of like in uh we're we're
kind of a little bit different because
we're
more of a specialty farm we grow
vegetables and we pretty much sell to
the local economy
which is perfect that's awesome see that
was one that's perfect
at all see that's great and see you know
more about it than i do and that's what
i was trying to get at is this a risky
uh or very stable type farming product
that you are putting down and the answer
is it's stable so
i think you bust it really hard in the
off season and pay that 20 grand off
and then you know you could still keep
side hustling it
for a while you know and uh get that
emergency fund where it needs to be
uh put that extra on the farm i try to
find ways to make more money on that
farm and pay that 350 off i think that's
your goal i think you're
i think you get gazelle intense man i
don't think you sell the farm i think
you get gazelle intense and realize that
this is my dream and i can make this
dream more stable
if i actually go all in on dave ramsey's
baby steps makes sense
yeah so hey chris are you answering my
question pretty much
chris you're married yeah when's the
last time you and your wife
went on a date a couple weeks ago
all right so here's a boy here's what
i'm gonna do um
we love farmers and i love giving away
other people's things so
if you will commit to going all in all
in on following the baby steps starting
from start to finish
you're in a rare place where your family
had a farm it was able to pass through
to you
you got a great deal on it you love the
work it's hard
every day hot and cold and dusty and
dirty work but you
love it i'm going to give you ramsey
plus for a year hey hey
and you're going to sit down and watch
that with your wife y'all going to go
through it together and
i'm going to give you a ticket to date
night mer
money and marriage live stream february
12th that's next friday 7 p.m me and
rachel cruz
we're going to be um it's a it's an
all-in date night you and your wife
is going to sit on the couch turn on the
tv and it's going to be romance we're
going to make you all have to
have some hard conversations teach you
guys how to dream together about money
and then i want you just to let the
shackles go we can hear it in your voice
man
be certain you're going to be in this
together and then grow this awesome farm
and then
pay it off so you can hand it off to one
day they're going to come here and do
their debt-free scream and bring us some
fresh fruit that's what they're going to
do
that would be huh you like where my
head's at i love
that this is the dave ramsey show
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help get you there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
this is the dave ramsey show i'm john
delony with my good friend ken coleman
give us a shout at two 825-5225
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's go to lindsay
in woodbridge virginia lindsey how are
you doing
i'm good thank you for taking my call
today you bet thanks for giving us a
shout what's going on
so i have a question about baby step two
and whether or not i need to put money
aside for a possible divorce
so i've been married for eight years i
have several young children
i am the working mom and then my husband
is a stay-at-home dad
great dad really good dad um and we are
really great roommates we're best
friends we do everything together
but from the day we got married i knew
there was something wrong
i initially thought there was something
wrong with me because we had
no intimacy no you know
cuddling just that there was something
wrong i found out during my last
pregnant just a couple years ago that he
crawl stresses and he has been in a
relationship with at least one other man
prior to getting married to me nothing
after getting married to me that i know
of
um i can't
be attracted to someone who is actively
cross-dressing and he
is not interested in anything without it
okay and so
while we are really good roommates i am
very very lonely
very lonely and some days i just don't
think i can do it
but other than that we are a really you
know we're good friends our kids are
happy
i don't think our kids have any clue
that we have any relationship problems
and so with us being in the middle of
baby step two we've paid off about two
hundred thousand we have just under two
hundred thousand to go
uh are you a doctor yes i am okay there
you go
i was gonna say man that's a lot of
student loans right great guess
yes but we're almost done yeah um
i i don't know should i stop it and put
money aside for a possible divorce or if
i am
content enough should i just keep
going and keep working on the baby steps
and just ignore that aspect we have
tried counseling he's not interested in
any changes he's not interested in
following up and counseling so where
does that put you
when you say possible divorce he's not
interested in any counseling
you've already expressed your emotion
and where you're at so what's
where are you at when you say possible
divorce
while i'm content most of the time i am
so lonely sometimes i don't know how
long i can stay married to someone
lindsay what kind of testimony what kind
of doctor are you
i'm primary care okay so i can i'm gonna
speak to you
like a fellow geek for a second is that
okay
um you know the the jama
the journal of american medical
association you know the diseases of
despair
data don't you yes we are amidst a
loneliness epidemic that is
killing us through
all sorts of chaotic inflammatory
responses
right whether it is addiction
or whether it is people taking their own
lives or whether it is
what the articles are calling long tail
suicide
through organ disease failure right
and so i'm just speaking geek to you for
a second
as a way to to soften the blow here
but you can't live a life of loneliness
just because he's a great father
just because y'all are great roommates
doesn't mean
that you've got to stay married and
you've got to stay lonely
right part of um
part of a marriage is two people working
together
to co-create a future and i don't care
what the other
like the the the fact that he has
been with other people the fact that he
has a way of
um showing his authenticity to himself
to his core group of people
and you have said i don't want to be a
part of that moving forward and he has
said well tough luck
then i don't want to be the one to tell
you this lindsay but you called the show
he has
said my authenticity in this moment is
more important than being
married to you yeah that's a really nice
way saying that i'm going to jump in and
say he's made it very clear he doesn't
want to be married to you he doesn't
want to fix it this is a whole different
deal
or he wants to be married on his terms
right i can't
i just don't that's not being married so
there is a relationship contract it's
not a legal document me
i think married is we are together
that's right that's right no
it's not just in the same house this guy
made me a fantastic
fantastic roommate but you're gonna
crash you're going to crash hard you
have crashed haven't you
you might have uh-huh
i was admitted for depression a couple
of years ago but i've gotten to the
point where i recognize it wasn't
my failing in the marriage i gave it
everything i had sure
yeah so yeah so what's left what are you
waiting on
it's hard to do it looking at my kids
yep it is yeah that's that's that's true
uh let's talk about the financial piece
john here because
you've got 200 000 left so yeah we want
you to pause because you're in the midst
of a
really big storm and so you need to
pause paying off the
the debt snowball until we until we
figure out
the when the how yeah what's that going
to look like i mean it's just too
uncertain so
we want to pause right that's the
financial piece the financial piece is
um yes you got to pause the baby steps
and
because you have a as in to use your
words because y'all are still best
friends
because you've got a good relationship
you can sit down and have this
it's going to be a very hard very
challenging but a factual conversation
here's where we are at
and i'm not willing to
continue to be lonely inside my own home
anymore
and you've made it clear that you're not
interested in co-creating a future
together with me
and so as ken said as i said
your husband's painting the picture for
you right and now not by your hand but
in your lap now you're forced to make
some hard decisions
and here's where we are and i don't know
that you're going to find two people
more high on marriage than ken and i um
i'm not
in the business of telling people in
their marriage but i am in the business
of telling the truth and the reality is
lindsay you've told me your marriage is
over
and that it is at this point it's
drowning you yeah
and i'm not gonna sit by and watch a
friend
be drowned right so yeah as far as the
money goes
hard conversation you got to pause the
baby steps you're all going to have to
um make some hard decisions about how
you're going to move forward together
how are you going to work out the
parenting all that stuff's going to have
to happen together
this is not going to be an easy road
moving forward i hope everybody can act
like an adult and y'all can work
together in this transition
and i always always always i'm going to
circle back to my hope for
reconciliation for people to come
together but you've been doing that for
a long time
and so it's time to call what it is what
it is and make the hard hard decisions
together
and then continue to honor each other
around your kids
don't ever ever ever be in the
badmouthing game
either of you honor each other in front
of your kids and this is gonna be a hard
hard season to walk
um and i want to thank you for honoring
us with your trust here i know this is a
hard call to make
and um we'll be thinking about you
moving forward yeah and i would just say
this that you know
you've done some great things in in
paying off 200 000
worth of debt you're going through some
extremely extremely painful stuff
personally
pressing pause don't feel guilty for
that for a second you work through all
this that john said and then there's
going to be a season where you'll be
able to pick back up and you'll get
there
and uh hopefully it's whole uh in a in a
healthy relationship where you're not
alone
so and i want to call it we'll second
guess it let's let's um in key
i think it's important to not
let people off the hook here it's easy
to hear a call like this and go
i don't know anybody who dresses in
women's clothes or who feels this way or
is attracted to people
i get this call all the time ken about
video games
and about alcohol and about spending
money and about
have to have another car and a house
this size where you get somebody who's
married
and the person they're married to says
i'm doing my life
this way without you that's right that's
exactly right without yeah that's right
the really the details and the
sensational whatever you think is
sensational whether you don't think it's
sensational
the fact of the matter is is when one of
the spouses says i'm not interested in
counseling which means i'm not
interested in reconciliation i'm not
interested
and they've been unfaithful
[Music]
then you know it's not by your hand but
in your lap and you've got some hearts
so
you've been forced to deal with it and
so you don't quit living you keep moving
i hate that for
i really do and the kids stay in there
lindsay stay in there
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day is first john 3
20
for whenever our heart condemns us god
is greater than our heart
and he knows everything
rosa parks says stand for something or
you will
fall for anything today's mighty oak
is yesterday's nut that held its ground
that's a great quote
all right let's go to curt in columbus
ohio kurt how are we doing
how are you doing today outstanding
brother how can we help
um so i'm fairly new to the whole dave
ramsey program trying to figure out the
best way to attack
my debt i am currently engaged
me and my fiance are going to get
married in june
um and so i have roughly about 8 000
in a car loan that i'm working on paying
off
hopefully without getting crazy with
that i should be able to cut off like a
year and a half
she's going to have about 40 000 in
student loans
i know i have about 18 000
in investments that i've been thinking
about selling off to
pay off the car and she is about 10 in
her savings account
my question was should i hold on to
selling what i have in the stock market
to wait to pay off her student loans
because we have six months of interest
free with those or should i go ahead and
sell
to pay off pay off the car loan faster
and then we'll be paying on the student
loans for i'm
figuring for about eight months to a
year
after after we get married what's do you
have single stocks in the stock market
or are you talking about cashing out a
retirement plan
uh no that's separate from what i have
in my retirement that would that would
just be non-retirement investments
like what uh it's just uh
uh s p uh uh
i don't know that's the stock spy it's
just a
mutual fund tracker so how much is it
worth if you cashed in today what are we
talking about that stock
uh it's just over if i sold everything
it'd be just over eighteen thousand
yeah but you're gonna take a hit are you
gonna take it no no hit on that okay so
he's gonna get that so i
how much is the car worth uh the car
i owe like i owe about eight on it but
the car if i would sell it i could sell
it for about 15.
hey i like that better yes uh i like
that better
um but you could sell the single stocks
yeah
i'm selling every single stock i got and
i'm gonna pay off stuff if you can get
money for your car
and get into a cheaper car but yeah sell
your single stocks today and get out
and pay your debt off smallest to
largest don't over complicate this
system
you're somebody that loves the adventure
and the risk and coming up with a scheme
aren't you
um hey brother i'm the same way dude
like i can't tell you when me and my
wife were going through this
i had hey listen honey i figured out a
new way
to sideways this deal and to go around
the loopty loops and do somersault
here's the thing man put your debts in
order smallest to largest
get a thousand dollar emergency fund
which is going to freak you out
cash out your single stocks and pay this
stuff off yeah so let's run through
these numbers
okay so you said you can sell the single
stocks and get 18 grand correct
yeah all right so the cars you got 8 000
debt so that's going to leave you 10
left over
you're going to put the thousand dollars
into the emergency fund so that gives
you nine grand
right right okay and the cars paid off
and and and you know the fiat i'd save
the nine
and when when we actually walked down
the aisle i'd put the nine put the nine
on there for her
and do you have that's going to knock it
down to 31 for her student loans and
then you guys attack that remaining 31
000 with a vengeance you guys are going
to pay that off quick
you had a payoff date of about eight
nine months i thought you said correct
for the forty thousand uh yes it's yeah
she had she has about
ten and saving in her own savings and
i've talked to her and she's getting on
board
done oh hello so now we so so now we
take her ten because you've got the one
thousand yep that john had you put away
and so now i've got that at about 21 000
if i did my math right
and then you got two incomes y'all are
going to crush this you're not going to
do anything dumb
like go buy a eight bedroom house your
first two weeks of being married you're
going to go be smart you're going to use
bedroom house you're gonna use both
incomes you're gonna
knock this out and asap yeah and then
you're gonna be able to breathe
and then you're gonna be able to enjoy
your marriage debt-free with no strings
no chains no nothing that's how you do
it
all right yeah man now it's 21 000 after
you make all those moves you're only
gonna have 21 000 to attack together
that's great or you can do this curt you
can hang on to that stock
and in six months it's going to drop in
half and then you're going to be calling
us back going hey how do i
figure this one out too right hey
you know what to do you're a smart guy
put all your creative energy
in wooing and falling deeper in love
with your wife
follow the plan that millions have
followed step by step by step and i want
to point something out because i
misunderstood for a second but it's like
i heard that retirement never
ever ever cash out retirement no never
ever ever ever cash out 401k or
retirement funds to pay off debt okay
that's where you take the tax
hit and you end up not doing it so that
so just want to be clear because we have
a lot of new listeners come in there
uh you don't touch that but the stocks
yes that's a good move
single stock selling yeah that's risky
as it is most people lose their shirt on
that deal yeah
so there you go all right let's take one
more quick call to luke in meridian
idaho luke are you anywhere near
pocatello
uh about three hours away that's what
i'm talking about hey
hold up listen we had a good friend here
from pocatello that called his name is
nick flowers
he sent us some pocatello high school we
needed to give
quick context and then get to the call
we had nick on what a week ago when we
were on together
and we loved the name pocatello so much
we got excited about it because we both
have adhd
and and i said is there a pocatello high
school he said yes i said i'd love some
memorabilia i was totally goofing off
nick sent you a t-shirt and sent me this
hoodie they hooked us up so
shout out to nick uh for the free hoodie
that's right so
luke that's not why you called i just
got excited because you're near
pocatello my
third or fourth favorite city in the
country now but you can uh
save meridian here how can we help
um yeah so i'm just looking for uh for
some advice on some opportunities that
uh
opened up um so basically uh i had a
internship over in the uk that opened up
recently um that i got into
um about something i'm like pretty
passionate about okay um
but i also have applications currently
in to uh
west point and the naval academy whoa um
and so
basically i would leave in april and
then um
if i got into the academies i would come
back in june so i was just wondering if
i should take that
um or just like stay home and enjoy my
time before i make a
pretty big commitment to west point or
the naval academy well you applied to my
home for like
eight years yeah but luke you applied
for this internship because you wanted
to do it you thought it might be good
for you yes or no
yeah it's in the uk that's pretty cool
too great experience yes or no
yeah i think you do it i you haven't
given me one good reason why you
shouldn't do it
other than you're going to be going away
and i understand that so it's like if
you're worried about friends and family
and if that's your heart tugging at you
i think you listen to that too
what's really making you doubt the
decision to take this internship and go
to the uk
um financial part of it i guess is part
of it
um i have the money to do it it's just
going to come to my savings because i
have about
15 000 saves right now does it put you
on the path does this internship is it
going to
help you in the future uh
yes kind of okay
i mean here's the deal if if you've got
the money for it
and it is a good experience for you and
it actually is something that will
add value to your long-term goals
i'd do it but if it's just a pure fun
thing and you then you've got to weigh
it
you've got to weigh it what would you
rather have at the end of this time
the experience and less money or
more money and no experience i think
that's what it boils down to unless i'm
missing something so what are you
leaning towards right now
i'm leaning more towards just doing it
for at least two months and then
uh going to west point or the naval
academy i just come home
a little bit earlier than i normally
would do it john what do you think
for sure man yeah great experience
you're gonna miss out on like
all right bros let's all go hey or an
awesome opportunity
right okay i think one of the greatest
greatest experiences that any human
being can have is to see the world
to go to other cultures blew my mind
i got out of america and i got to see
large parts of the world and i was like
i'm really small not in kansas anymore
toto that's exactly right
like to thank james childs and kelly
daniel
for putting on another great show thank
you so much for being with us america
ken appreciate you always fun this has
been the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you